Пане Лінднере, уряд Німеччини й надалі вважає
проект "Північний потік-2" доцільним попри тиск
із боку США і деяких європейських країн.
На чиєму боці ви?
Ми виступаємо за загальноєвропейську
енергетичну зовнішню політику. Німеччина повинна
отримувати енергоносії з щонайбільшої кількості джерел.
Зокрема, з Росії, по можливості - з Європи.
До речі, це стосується і синтетичного палива,
й енергоносіїв, які можна отримати
з відновлювальних джерел енергії,
з діоксиду вуглецю, а також зрідженого газу зі США.
На мій погляд, проблема тут в тому, що
уряд Німеччини багато років лише спостерігав
за цим приватним економічним проектом,
а занепокоєння наших партнерів та друзів по ЄС не враховувались.
Це ж не чисто економічний проект, він матиме
масштабні зовнішньополітичні наслідки. Тому ми
рекомендуємо обговорювати ці питання в європейському контексті.
І навіть зараз, коли третина трубопроводу вже збудована?
Так, це недоліки, помилки. Але я вважаю, що
альтернативи немає, не можна просто ігнорувати
сумніви наших партнерів. Потрібно також
враховувати інтереси України - вони легітимні.
Правда, я все ж хочу сказати, що найближчими
десятиліттями, попри наше бажання видобувати
енергію з відновлювальних джерел,
ми продовжуватимемо використовувати газ,
багато в чому через відмову від вугілля та ядерної енергетики,
навіть у більшій мірі і протягом більш тривалого
часу, ніж вважалося раніше.
Тому диверсифікація може мати сенс.
Але не на шкоду нашим партнерам та друзям.
Ви за чи проти "Північного потоку-2"?
Я за цей проект, якщо буде досягнуто консенсусу на загальноєвропейському рівні.
Ви вже згадали про відмову Німеччини від вугільної енергетики.
Це має статися не пізніше 2038 року. Ви раді цьому
чи швидше занепокоєні тим, що Німеччина буде
вимушена купувати більше газу в Росії?
Я швидше занепокоєний. У нас були традиційно
добрі енерго-економічні відносини колись
із Радянським Союзом, а нині - з Росією. Але ж ніхто
не може знати, що може статися. З цієї причини я -
за енергетичну безпеку, яка забезпечується
наявністю різних джерел енергоносіїв. Тому я
не вважаю правильним те, що радить комісія німецького уряду.
Так, ми маємо досягти цілей з боротьби зі зміною клімату,
але в якій галузі? Ми повинні вирішувати ці питання
ринковими методами, але в цьому напрямку
потрібно працювати в європейському контексті.
Але наші найбільші прорахунки ми зробили
не в енергетичній галузі, а в галузі транспорту,
викиду тепла, сільського господарства.
А нині ухвалене рішення про відмову від вугілля
без будь-якої на те потреби. Адже воно обійдеться
надто дорого при тому, що платити було не потрібно.
Усе можна було вирішити за допомогою емісійних сертифікатів.
Крім того, це веде до більшої залежності від деяких енергоносіїв
у Німеччині, зокрема, і країн-постачальників,
і цим не сприяє покращенню клімату.
Анексія Криму, втручання Росії у Східній Україні,
санкції Заходу діють вже майже протягом 5 років.
Позиція Путіна залишається незмінною.
Захід продовжує санкції знову і знову.
Наскільки правильна, на ваш погляд, політика
безкінечного продовження санкцій? Може, має сенс придумати щось нове?
Нині я не бачу альтернативи. Максимум, що можна
уявити в даному випадку, - це посилення санкцій.
Якщо санкції не дають результатів, то найбільше,
що можна зробити, - це їх ще посилити. Я б залюбки
повернувся до співпраці з Росією. Думаю, це було б
в інтересах усіх задіяних сторін. Наприклад,
розширення співпраці в галузі торгівлі.
Путін сам у своїй промові в Бундестазі на початку
минулого десятиліття виступив за створення зони вільної торгівлі.
Сьогодні така ідея абсолютно нереалістична.
Але треба думати про довгострокову перспективу.
Якщо працювати над розширенням співпраці, то
і ця тема може стати предметом обговорення.
Нині ми стоїмо на порозі нового витка ядерної гонки озброєння,
яку насправді Росія не може собі дозволити
з фінансової точки зору. Там є і проблеми
внутрішньої політики, і соціальної системи,
наприклад, питання пенсійного забезпечення, які
опиняться в центрі уваги. Думаю, ми повинні
залишатися послідовними щодо санкцій,
а також у питаннях ядерного озброєння,
але в той самий час поєднувати це все з закликами до співпраці.
Наприклад, запропонувати Російській Федерації та її президенту
повернутися в формат "великої вісімки". І якщо
під час перемовин з цього приводу з'ясується, що є
можливість для співпраці, то можна було б
подумати про покрокове скасування санкцій.
Але не так, як це пропонує зробити той чи інший
німецький соціал-демократ, так би мовити, як аванс із боку Заходу.
Ви справді хотіли б відродити "велику вісімку"?
Так, адже саме коли відносини ускладнені,
відсутність переговорів - не альтернатива.
Мене завжди дивує, що від перемовин
відмовляються саме тоді, коли виникають проблеми.
Наприклад, як ви пам'ятаєте, зустріч
американського і російського президентів
не сталася через кризу довкола Керченської протоки.
А це могло б стати приводом для того, щоб
обговорити проблеми один з одним. Не розумію,
чому в критичних ситуаціях відмовляються від дипломатії.
Я завжди думав, що у кризових ситуаціях немає нічого важливішого за діалог.
1,5 року тому вас жорстко критикували за те, що ви
сказали під час виборчої кампанії. Потім ви дещо
пом'якшили свою позицію. Ви сказали: "Я побоююсь,
що поки Крим варто розглядати як тимчасове рішення на невизначений термін".
Яким є ваше ставлення до Криму сьогодні?
Воно не змінилося. Я ніколи його не пом'якшував.
Йдеться не про те, щоб погодитись із порушенням
Росією міжнародного права. Ми - партія правової держави,
це теж стосується і міжнародного права.
Але якщо ми справді хочемо розрядки, а не ескалації,
то найскладніше питання буде на завершальній стадії
процесу налагодження взаєморозуміння, а не на його початку.
Це досвід, який ми маємо ще з часу падіння "залізної завіси".
На початку процесу розрядки стояли Гельсінські угоди.
І якби тоді, наприклад, протиправна анексія
балтійських держав Радянським Союзом
не розглядалася з нашого боку як тимчасове рішення,
то не було б жодного процесу розрядки,
жодних договорів про роззброєння,
жодної "гласності", перебудови та падіння залізної завіси.
Аналогічно з цим я би радив розглядати Крим
як тимчасове рішення, але не погоджуватися з анексією,
не визнавати її. І не робити з цього питання наріжний камінь.
Адже є й інші питання - наприклад, ситуація на Сході України,
чи є там якісь просування? Питання в тому, що має намір
робити Путін далі зі своїми ядерними ракетами середньої дальності,
що порушують договір,
питання в тому, коли в НАТО
повернеться посол Росії,
адже ця посада є ознакою готовності до діалогу.
Є безліч інших питань, за якими можна було б
досягти прогресу для того, щоб пізніше почати говорити про Крим.
Але така позиція спричинить різку критику з боку України.
З цим треба буде жити. У мене складається враження,
що критика, яка звідти лунає, нерідко має внутрішньополітичний характер.
Там теж вирішується питання, хто керуватиме країною в майбутньому.
Ми вже зачепили тему Договору про ракети середньої та малої дальності.
Він буде призупинений. Путін відмовляється йти назустріч Заходу і
навпаки, має намір нарощувати озброєння. Чи має НАТО відповісти так само в Європі?
Досягти порозуміння з Росією в цьому питанні можна буде лише тоді,
якщо у нас буде можливість піти на переконливу крайню міру.
Ми цього не хочемо. Наша партія виступає
за роззброєння та обмеження розповсюдження ядерного озброєння.
Ми, ліберали, завжди прагнули, щоб у світі не було ядерної зброї.
Навіть якщо це сьогодні виглядає утопічно, така мета заслуговує на підтримку.
Однак діалогу та роззброєння можна буде досягти, власне,
як і в часи укладення подвійного рішення НАТО,
якщо буде зрозуміло, що в критичній ситуації країни НАТО знов утворять паритет.
Чи будуть це ядерні ракети середньої дальності,
чи інші засоби залякування, -
у 2019 році все це потрібно оцінювати
по-новому, а не так, як у 1980-ті роки.
Може, це будуть ракети, а може, й інші системи.
Ми ж не хочемо вертатися до логіки тих часів.
Тому було б добре, якби канцлерка ФРН Анґела Меркель,
яка й надалі має великий вплив та світовій арені,
організувала між Москвою і Вашингтоном, а також
між Пекіном та Ісламабадом, човникову дипломатію.
Мені, звісно, відомо, що в Росії є інтереси в галузі безпеки,
які стосуються ядерного арсеналу Китайської народної республіки
і які не враховані в договорі про РСМД, який був
білатеральною угодою. Тож його наступником
має стати багатосторонній договір.
Хто, як не Німеччина, має боротися за багатосторонні договори?
Це могло б стати пріоритетом для пані Меркель.
А якщо таки дійде до розміщення ядерних ракет у Німеччині?
Як сказав, у нас в Німеччині вже розміщені ядерні озброєння.
Але відповіддю на нові ракетні системи Росії
не повинні бути обов'язково нові ядерні ракетні системи НАТО в Німеччині.
Є й інші технології. Але якщо виникає така потреба -
ви, судячи з усього, хочете присадити мене цим питанням
і я не буду ухилятися від відповіді, -
якщо єдиною можливістю дати відсіч спробам
ядерного шантажу буде розгортання таких самих систем у себе,
тоді Німеччина повинна буде провести суспільну дискусію з цього приводу.
Тоді ми не будемо ухилятися від відповіді,
ми не робили цього і в часи ухвалення подвійного рішення НАТО.
Але дуже б не хотілося назад, у ті часи!
Дуже дякую, пане Лінднере.
Дякую вам!